they never considered him a legitimate
president they couldn't allow themselves
to well after all if a man was zero
political experience could take down the
Clintons the Obamas the Bush's the
entire media establishment in a
legitimate election well what would that
have said about the Democratic brand
early on left-wing activists the deep
state and the DC swamp decided to devote
all of their waking hours to a smear and
slash campaign with the goal of
convincing you that this trump
presidency was invalid I don't see this
president-elect has a legitimate
president
there's a cloud of illegitimate see
that's hanging over the White House
an illegitimate and criminal regime in
the American white house
he's an illegitimate president in my
mind folks look I absolutely agree
he knows he's an illegitimate president
and three years later undeterred by
their mother flame out the Democrats are
at it again this time their outlandish
claim emerges from the impeachment
circus itself we all know unless
something really bizarre happens in the
next 24 hours President Trump will
surely be acquitted by the Senate and
that should be the last word on it right
wrong it will not be acquitted you
cannot be acquitted if you don't have a
trial no trial no vindication no
vindication for the President or anyone
else a trial without truth without key
evidence without witnesses and documents
would render the president's acquittal
meaningless that's a cute trick so the
Democrat position just so you understand
is that any acquittal in a trial where
they didn't get their way is it
legitimate
it's a classic heads I win tails you
lose scenario and it's so predictable
and don't buy for a second the argument
that this is all about witnesses or
documents it's not this is about power
if two or three or ten witnesses were
followed by an acquittal of Trump you'd
still hear Nancy and Kamala challenging
the outcome this is how the Democrats
always play the game remember to this
day they don't consider Brett Kavanaugh
a legitimate Supreme Court justice the
very fact that he's there that he was
confirmed makes him an element
illegitimate justice he's gonna be on
the Supreme Court with a huge taint and
a big asterisk after his name there will
be a cloud and a taint hovering over him
and every opinion that he issues the
read of the same people saying the same
stuff
well they don't consider any of the
successes of this presidency to be
legitimate victories for him even on
issues they agree with President Trump
on that's the amazing thing here while
being hunted and tracked like wild game
on the Serengeti the president has
delivered sustained peace and
unprecedented
prosperity to this country of course
major trade deals massive economic
success criminal justice reform VA
reform declining opioid deaths but to
Pelosi shift Schumer and Alec these are
just flukes or to put it a different way
fruits of a poisonous illegitimate
presidential tree how ironic that this
odious impeachment Odyssey is itself the
epitome of an illegitimate undertaking
this entire proceeding here is now the
fruit of the poisonous tree it is the
fruit of a proceeding that was fatally
deficient in due process from the start
to the beginning and as a result of that
it produced a record that is totally
unreliable can't be relied on here for
any conclusion other than a quitting the
president anything's illegitimate it's
with Adam Schiff Nadler the whole crew
did in the House of Representatives
courtesy of a whistleblower no one can
question an IG whose transcript no one
can read and one more point of irony
here after impeaching the president
based on the Ukraine actions that they
claimed were politically and personally
motivated two of the top house managers
may be driving this agonizing episode in
large part to bolster their own
political futures that's right Schiff
and Hakeem Jeffries are now dubbed the
two superstars of the impeachment drama
give me a break Dancing with the Stars
is about as high as these two will ever
rise well anyone and everyone knows how
this movie ends the president will not
be removed from office and the Democrats
will continue wasting precious time and
our money attempting to entrap him or
just smear him until the election in
calling Trump and his forthcoming
acquittal illegitimate the Democrats are
kettles calling the pots black with each
crazy utterance they degrade their
diminished credibility and expose their
own abuse of power but the good news is
the American people could end the
Democrats reign of terror and the
hateful cycle they've trapped us all in
deliverance is just around the corner
it's called the November election and
that's the angle